ibiza fait parler d'elle depuis que
plusieurs joueurs du psg en sont revenus
positifs au coville 19
cette île des baléares et la destination
incontournable des stars et des fêtards
depuis de nombreuses années retour sur
une métamorphose qui a débuté dans les
années 70
à l'origine ibiza c'est une île prisée
de la communauté hippie dans les années
60 elle est encore à l'abri du tourisme
de masse
7 il existe toujours et elle n'a point
changé c'est ibiza perles des balais à
la vie coule lentement leur espagnol
entre les murs des pâtures nombreux dans
le champ des fresh fontaine
mais très rapidement les vacanciers font
leur arrivée les liaisons maritimes et
aériennes avec lille se multiplient il
est même possible d'y faire transporter
sa voiture par avion
résultat les hôtels se développent des
activités touristiques aussi sans doute
comme les autres touristes européens
sont ils venus chercher ici le soleil le
repo et peut-être aussi une certaine
douceur de vivre
promise par tous les dépliants
touristiques années 80 ibiza devient une
île à la mode une voiture porte même son
nom et sur le port les fêtards se
retrouvent pour danser boire ou fumer à
ibiza les drogues douces sont tolérés
choses à faire ici l'un d'eux joint
rencontré plein de bars c'est super la
nuit je n'avais jamais vu autant de gens
fumer librement comme ça dans la rue à
partir des années 90 la musique
électronique envahi ibiza l'île devient
le lieu où il faut être pour les dj à
l'image de david guetta
en 2009 le français rassemblés près de
6000 personnes dans une boîte de nuit
si on a la soirée qui cartonne ici en
tant que dj on sait que derrière en gros
le carnet de commandes ne va pas
désemplir toute l'année dans le reste du
monde le temple de la nuit a été frappé
de plein fouet par la crise sanitaire
les grandes discothèques sont toujours
fermés les rues sont vides
ironie du sort il a retrouvé sa
tranquillité perdue des années 60
[Musique]